hello i'm mariam namazi in london our
main story this hour us officials have
admitted that a drone strike in kabul
last month mistakenly killed 10
civilians and not isil fighters an
investigation found the august 29 strike
killed an innocent aid worker along with
nine members of his family including
seven children the strike was one of the
us military's final acts in afghanistan
before ending its 20-year military
operation there
i am now convinced that as many as 10
civilians including up to seven children
were tragically killed in that strike
moreover we now assess that it is
unlikely that the vehicle and those who
died were associated with isis k or were
a direct threat to u.s forces
i offer my profound condolences to the
family and friends of those who were
killed
this strike was taken in the earnest
belief that it would prevent an imminent
threat to our forces and the evacuees at
the airport but it was a mistake
and i offer my sincere apology
as the combatant commander i am fully
responsible for this strike in this
tragic outcome
shia bratanzi joins us live now from
washington important very important
conclusions in the advocate
investigation chad but also what is the
significance of the way in which this
information came to light
that's the big question would there have
been an investigation had the new york
times happen to have still a substantial
team on the ground in kabul who could
talk to those involved in the strike the
victims the survivors and say what
actually happened because otherwise
clearly this would have gone down in the
annals of history as in the words of the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff a
righteous strike against isis k but we
should be clear here though this isn't
some new phenomenon because the us's no
longer has eyes on the ground this is a
feature of the war on terror that we've
been covering since 2008 it's
particularly a feature of signature
strikes in the drone wars that were
introduced by george w bush but then
really embraced and pioneered by barack
obama
and the point of those is when a drone
operator sees behavior that has the
signature or bears a signature of
militant activity you bomb and the
assumption is that everyone killed was a
combatant unless it can be proven that
they weren't a competent and how often
is there a full new york team's group
team on the ground to check all of that
this is what the pentagon's been relying
on all these years we who knows how many
times this has happened in the past so
to then i think i can see now that the
discussion in the media here in the u.s
is oh well doesn't that doesn't that
mean that the u.s shouldn't have left
afghanistan we don't know we no longer
have eyes on the ground this is what
over the horizon war looks like it's
kind of missing the point that's a red
herring civilians were being killed even
when the u.s had eyes on the ground
wherever they are through drone wars and
through through through the the rules of
engagement that the u.s u.s already has
and we know anyway that civilians were
being killed whether
whether the u.s had you know have people
there or not whether it's by drone or
whether it's by the troops who are in
fact stationed there the new yorker had
a great piece just last week talking
about all the untold hundreds of
civilians who were being killed rather
routinely by the u.s who we don't know
anything about so this is just another
example not so much it's not so much
relevant to the pull-out from
afghanistan but once again relevant to
the rules of engagement in the us's
drone wars which of course joe biden and
certainly president obama and president
trump actually he escalated them
enormously too are relying on
increasingly out instead of having a
large footprint on the ground thank you
very much rehab britancy in washington
and just one other story we're following
this hour france has recalled its
ambassadors to the united states and
australia as part of a massive dip